CaCastonguay, Luc Ferrandez ais,
bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On a vu u le vote de grève a
étété donnée à un des syndicats
ququi représentent les
édéducatrices, il y en a un aute
ququ'on attend demain, plus groe
sysyndicats.
OnOn va entendre Madame Grenon t
onon va entendre l'ministre
réréponde.
VAVALÉRIE GRENON,
prprésidente, FIPEQ
- - Si on peut avoir
unun calendrier intensif
vevendredi, samedi, dimanche
lulundi, bien, on va le prendre.
OnOn veut négocier et régler.
SiSi j'utilise les mêmes termes
quque Madame Lebel, "Le tango, a
sese danse à deux." Fait que no,
lele plancher de danse est prêt.
OnOn veut danser à tous les jou,
dodonc si on peut négocier
jojour et nuit, on va le faire
popour régler enfin cette négo t
évéviter les problématiques pour
leles parents.
- - (journaliste): Est-ce
quque ça avance ou ça avance pa,
llà, de votre perception à vous?
SOSONIA LeBEL, présidente
CoConseil du Trésor du Québec
- - Là, présentement, j'avoue
quque c'est très difficile sur
l'l'enjeu qui a été clair depuis
lele début par le gouvernement
ququ'on ne pourra pas être
enen mesure d'offrir la même...
lala même hauteur, la même
cacapacité d'augmentation
popour tous les secteurs du CPE.
- - Parce que pour les
édéducatrices, le gouvernement x
prpremiers échelons, Martine,
prproposer de faire passer le 19
lele 19 a...
AlAlors rapport de force qui
s'installe et ils ont beaucoup
dede pouvoir.
- - Il y a définitivement, Madae
GrGrenon disait, il en faut deux
ouou pour dire pendant ça tango.
IlIl danse, je vous dirai.
IlIl devrait fatiguer de danser,
paparce qu'ils dansent beaucoup.
OnOn s'attendait à avoir un vote
dede grève aussi fort et on
s's'attend à un vote de grève
dedemain.
AlAlors il y a une grosse
ststratégie qui se joue là-dess.
PoPour les éducatrices...
IlIl y a beaucoup de petits
dédétails les employés qu'on dit
dede soutien, il y en a plusieu,
ilil y en a que ce sont une
poportion minime de travail.
AlAlors c'est compliqué d'établr
totout cela.
PoPour les éducatrices, l'offre
esest de 12 % du gouvernement, a
dedemandé de...
LeLe gouvernement se situe à 20.
PoPour les employés de soutien,n
vava dans une fourchette assez
lalarge, mais ça négocie.
LeLe dossier avance.
MaMais c'est sûr qu'il y a un
rarapport de force qui s'instal.
- - Qui a le plus gros bout du
bbâton, Alec?
- - Les parents sont pris entre
leles deux.
JeJe voudrais qu'au début de cee
nénégociation, il était résolumt
dudu côté des éducatrices en
gagarderie...
PlPlus le temps passe, plus il e
sisitue du côté du gouvernement.
OnOn a entendu M Madame Grenon
didire...
cece qu'on perçoit ce qui est il
n'n'y a que le gouvernement qui
dadanse depuis le début.
DaDans le cas des éducatrices à
tetemps pleines, on est même à 3
% % d'augmentation.
LeLes gens se disent, je suis
d'd'accord qu'elles valorisent
leleur emploi...
IlIl n'y a pas beaucoup de
trtravailleurs que tienne autant
d'd'argent si peu de temps.
MaMais alors c'est clair que les
grgrèves commencent à peser sur
leles parents.
- - Bien sûr, je l'ai peut-être
papas mentionné assez clairemen,
ilil y a le spectre de grève
ququi... mais Luc, ce n'est pas
imimpensable que ça n'arrive pas
nonon plus?
- - Non, parce que le syndicat..
EtEt le gouvernement veut ouvrir
3737... nouvelle place dans le
réréseau.
AlAlors il dit que si on veut
avavoir une nouvelle une capacié
àà ouvrer des places dans le
réréseau, on est légitime surtot
dadans un contexte de pénurie de
mamain-d'oeuvre de demander le
mamaximum.
- - Oui et c'est ce qu'elle
dedemande.
OnOn verra demain l'CSN. Martin,
çaça va peut-être se régler dans
lele bureau du premier ministre
dadans deux semaines?
- - Un moment donné, le dernier
totour de roue va se donner.
ChChez Sonia LeBel on a quand me
bobon espoir de régler, on se rd
cocompte que c'est quand même
cocomplexe.
- - Très bien.
OnOn revient sur l'histoire DES
CHCHSLD. Mme McCann qui voulait
rérépondre, parce que elle était
reresponsable à l'époque.
OnOn va écouter Mme McCann qui
plplaide que il y a eu des envos
dede signaux dès le mois de
jajanvier dit-on.
DADANIELLE McCANN, ministre
dede l'Enseignement supérieur
- - C'est une lettre qui parle
dedes établissements, au sens
lalarge, là. Il est pas mention
nonon plus des hôpitaux
dadans cette lettre-là.
OnOn ne mentionne pas des volets
d'd'établissements spécifiques.
C'C'est unun plan global.
MaMais on dit : vous devez
prpréparer l'ensemble de vos
ététablissements à faire face
àà une menace qui s'appelle
unun nouveau coronavirus.
DoDonc, ça fait appel à l'enseme
dedes établissements.
EtEt évidemment, on a commencé
àà travailler tout de suite,
enen février.
- - Bon, Martine, qu'est-ce qu'n
apapprend est-ce qu'on apprend
ququelque chose aujourd'hui?
- - Oui et non.
C'C'est-à-dire, je pense que le
rarapport de la protectrice du
cicitoyen parle de lui-même.
C'C'est-à-dire que les CHSLD ont
étété laissés à eux-mêmes.
L'L'enjeu c'est maintenant,
ququ'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
leles CHSLD?
C'C'est un peu dans la situation
dadans laquelle se retrouve le
gogouvernement.
AÀ peu près tout le monde sait
quque c'était compliqué et que e
gogouvernement avait mal placé s
bibilles, que c'était trop...
QuQu'il avait trop insisté sur s
hhôpitaux.
MaMaintenant il a insisté sur
trtrois rapports.
IlIl reste le rapport de
l'l'coronaire et le rapport de a
cocommission de la santé.
HiHier, il y a eu un échange à
l'l'Assemblée nationale qui dist
totout.
LeLe ministre de la santé
rérépondait à une question et dt
: : on ne peut pas refaire
l'l'histoire.
IlIl a débuté Parti québécois a
didit : je comprends qu'on ne pt
papas refaire l'histoire, mais n
veveut la connaître l'histoire.
EtEt c'est là où on n'en est
auaujourd'hui.
LeLe gouvernement se retrouve sr
lala défensive tous les jours.
IlIl va devoir bricoler quelque
chchose pour qu'on en sache
ququelque chose.
- - L'opposition, évidemment,
n'n'allait pas se priver de ré
atattaquait le gouvernement là-
dedessus.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti lilibéral du Québec
- - La Protectrice du citoyen
nonous a dit : "Les signes
avavant-coureurs étaient là,
lele gouvernement savait
ququ'il y avait des risques
popour nos personnes
dadans les CHSLD et que
auaucun geste n'a été posé."
JOJOËL ARSENEAU, chef
paparlementaire, Parti québécois
- - Qui croire?
IlIl y a un enjeu ici
dede confiance de la population
etet des Québécois.
IlIl y a un enjeu d'intégrité.
EsEst-ce que le premier ministre
esest toujours prêt à se donner
unune note parfaite sur la gestn
dede la pandémie, ou va-t-il
dedemander une révision de note?
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - C'est une crise innommable
dadans l'histoire du Québec.
NoNous avons une dette envers
leles familles des gens disparu.
LaLa manière de rembourser
cecette dette, c'est de faire
totoute la lumière.
JeJe sais que le premier ministe
esest isolé, il a le dos au mur,
ilil contre-attaque. Pourquoi
rerefuse-t-il une commission
d'd'enquête publique?
- - Je lui demande qu'il me done
unun exemple de pouvoir
ququ'il manque à Mme Castonguay.
IlIl y a des réponses, là, qui..
ququi sont pas des réponses.
IlIl a rien à proposer, il a rin
dede concret à dire!
- - On le voit, allègue, il est
exexcédé.
IlIl a trois commissions
d'd'enquête, il y a trois enquês
didifférentes.
CÇa suffit-il je n'ai...
- - ce qui est ironique, c'est e
leles beaux l'opposition
réréclame...
leles témoignages qui proviennet
d'd'institutions qui font enquê.
IlIl va y avoir éventuellement
MaMadame Castonguay qui l'a
cocommise à la santé.
OnOn n'est pas dans une situatin
tytypique où les médias révèlent
leles informations à droite et à
gagauche sur un système qui sert
tototalement étonnant, que
pepersonne n'aurait jamais vu.
JeJe pense à des scandales de
cocorruption, ou la nomination s
jujuges à la commission
BaBastarache.
LLà, on part de loin il faut
dédécortiquer le système.
IlIl faut comprendre ce qui s'et
papassé pour...
PaParce qu'il n'y a pas de
ininstituts qui font enquête.
C'C'est ce qui alimente la périe
dede questions.
C'C'est pour ça que je dis que
c'c'est un peu ironique...
AlAlors qu'on a déjà beaucoup de
réréponses à nos questions déjà.
PoPour l'instant, je trouve quee
rarapport de la protectrice du
cicitoyen, à vraiment amener
bebeaucoup d'éclairage sur
plplusieurs aspects de la crise.
- - Mais elle ne fait pas la mêe
ananalyse que le premier minist.
ElElle est beaucoup plus dure.
ElElle dit : on les a laissé
totomber, on a transféré des ges
l'l'il n'est on n'était pas
éqéquipé.
- - Monsieur Legault est arrivé
avavec un...
ilil a fait preuve d'insouciance
dadans le dans son premier mand,
mamais le système de CHSLD est-
elelle et était dépourvu de
susuffisamment de personnel et e
susuffisamment de expertises.
C'C'était le cas.
AlAlors je ne vois pas pourquoil
nene fait pas simplement l l'av,
enen disant : oui c'est vrai, iy
a a un système à réformer, on
HaHagino ministre gestionnaire a
ttête, on ne formait 10 000
ememployés et on travail sur par
exexemple... comment l'encadrer?
EtEt Mme McCann, encore pire, en
prprétendant qu'il y avait une
lelettre qui circulait.
CeCe n'est pas une lettre qui
pepermettait de faire...
CeCe sont des réunions
ququotidiennes ce sont des
arargumentaires techniques, ce
sosont des outils techniques.
PoPourquoi est-ce qu'il s'obsti?
C'C'est du bonbon pour
l'l'opposition.
- - S'il n'y a pas d'élément
nonouveau...
- - l'opposition n'a pas de ces
réréponses.
OnOn ne sait et c'est difficilee
blblâmer le gouvernement.
CoComme Luc le dit, le
gogouvernement était pris avec e
réréseau de CHSLD qu'il y avait.
AÀ partir du moment où il s'est
rerendu compte que c'est avec...
C'C'est vrai que Monsieur Legaut
a a fait des efforts, c'est
dodocumenté, j'écris là-dessus t
àà les qualifier là-dessus.
OnOn sait qu'il y a eu des effos
popour régler la situation.
MaMais qu'est-ce qui s'est passà
l'l'intérieur des CHSLD.
EÉcoutez le reportage de du
cocollègue Gentile.
EtEt c'est un peu ce que les ges
veveulent savoir.
CoComment ça s'est passé?
CoComment à la pièce assez régl?
- - Ça la Corona ne va pas
rérépondre à ça?
- - C'est ça.
LeLes recommandations du rapport
dede la coronaire, les
rerecommandations du rapport dea
cocommission de la santé vont êe
imimportants.
- - D'ailleurs il un peu un pett
pepeu d'hier, et je lui ai poséa
ququestion à l'protectrice du
cicitoyen et à la dit...
elelle dit moi je vais être
cocorrect avec cela.
- - Absolument.
JeJe pense que la seule raison
avavec laquelle on veut que
l'l'enquête publique, c'est pour
ététirer... jusqu'à l'année
élélectorale.
C'C'est une stratégie évidente.
EtEt pourquoi Monsieur Legault t
alallé, l'Europe prêtée...
PoPourquoi est-ce qu'il a accepé
dede s'inscrire dans une négatin
ququi est impossible d'ailleurs,
paparce que c'est tellement bien
dodocumenté par l'protectrice du
cicitoyen.
CeCette tellement bien détaillé,
çaça fait pas de sens... il avat
jujusqu'à dire : on a agi au mix
nonos connaissances dans un
sysystème...
- - ça qu'on entre dans la
pspsychologie de quelqu'un qui
ététait au centre depuis le déb.
C'C'était épouvantable, on ne
gégérée.S'il disait cela... quad
ilils ont vu l'ampleur de la c e
crcrise.
- - Et contenu de ce qu'il avait
vuvu à l'époque
asassez différente où on a voulu
prprotéger les hôpitaux tôt pare
quque c'est ce qu'on voyait en
EuEurope, en Italie, à New Yorku
leles hôpitaux
OnOn a fait une erreur, on a
nénégligé un système de CHSLD ts
fafaible
cocoup, on est été mal préparé,n
avavait pas les équipements de
prprotection, bref.
- - Il ne dit pas comme ça
MoMonsieur Legault
- - Il dit : on a fait le mieux
popossible avec ce qu'on avait.
IlIl le dit différemment de moi.
- - Vous allez...
VoVous faites un peu plus loin
--
dede ce qu'on pensait
IlIls ont fait du mieux qu'il
popouvait... il le pense vraime.
mimieux qu'ils peuvent
ququ'ils le font,
papas le cas
çaça n'a pas de bon sens, on
dedevrait passer une loi pour
obobliger l'gouverneur général..
ouoù en êtes-vous là-dessus, tor
dede table.
- - En tant qu'institution, doit
êêtre bilingue et complètement
bibilingue.
EnEn tant que personne, on
cocomprend qu'elle ne le soit.
IlIl faut qu'à la fin de son
mamandat...
MoMonsieur Carignan à raison, ça
n'n'a pas de bon sens que la...
mamais donnons-lui une chance pr
ququ'elle puisse rejoindre ce
ststatut de.
- - À l'.
- - Je comprends le symbole qu'n
a a voulu appliquer du côté du
gogouvernement.
L'L'première gouverneur général
AuAutochtone.
EtEt je comprends qu'on est vouu
frfrapper un grand coup.
EtEt avec tout le contexte actu,
leles pensionnats autochtones.
OnOn devrait s'assurer que le
prochain ou l'prochain
gogouverneur général parle
frfrançais.
- - D'ailleurs, Dimitri soulage
nonous a révélé hier qu'elle étt
susur la courte liste pour être
nonominé en 2010.
EtEt Monsieur Harper dit : ellee
paparle pas français.
- - Son discours était très
cocorrect hier.
OnOn n'avait pas d'attente.
CeCe qui est surprenant, c'est a
nonomination.
PoPourquoi le premier ministre a
chchoisi de ne dominer quelqu'un
ququi ne parle pas les deux
lalangues officielles?
EtEt si sources, je trouve que
MoMonsieur Carignan n'a pas tor,
onon devrait encadrer que le
prpremier gouverneur général du
CaCanada parle français.
- - Elle peut montrer qu'elle
cocomprend les besoins de
l'l'institution au niveau
pepersonnel et devenir trilingu,
paparce qu'il est déjà bilingue.
- - En dehors de la chambre, son
trtravail c'est de rencontrer ds
gegens, c'est de représenter le
CaCanada en rencontrant des genà
trtravers le Canada.
IlIl va falloir qu'elle apprenne
lele français et qu'elle apprene
bibien.